ramón sospecha que los profesores de su
escuela técnica tienen en promedio menos
de 5 años de experiencia decide probar
su hipótesis nula la cual es que la
media de los años de experiencia que
tienen los profesores de la escuela es
igual a 5 años contra la hipótesis
alternativa la cual es que la media de
los años de experiencia que tienen los
profesores de la escuela es menor que
cinco años usando una muestra de 25
profesores la media de su muestra fue de
4 años esta fue su media y la desviación
estándar fue de 2 años ramón quiere usar
estos datos para realizar una prueba
tema en la media
además supón que se conocen todas las
condiciones para la inferencia calcula
el estadístico tel para la prueba de
ramón debe redondear tu respuesta a dos
decimales
vamos a recordar a qué se refiere el
problema tenemos por aquí nuestra
hipótesis nula la cual es que la media
de los años de experiencia que tienen
los profesores de la escuela es de 5
años mientras que la hipótesis
alternativa es que la media de los años
de experiencia que tienen los profesores
de la escuela es menor que 5 años
imagina que este círculo representa a
todos los profesores de su escuela
técnica que es la población entonces lo
que ramón hizo fue tomar una muestra de
25 de ellos por lo tanto n es igual a 25
y de esta muestra calculó un resumen
estadístico primero calculo que la media
de la muestra fue de 4 años y también
calculó la desviación estándar de la
muestra y es igual a 2 años
ahora lo más importante al hacer una
prueba de significancia es decir si
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener una media muestral menor o igual
a 4 y si esa probabilidad es menor que
un cierto valor de significancia
entonces rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
y sugeriremos la hipótesis alternativa
para calcular esta probabilidad
necesitamos hacer una prueba estadística
algunas veces usaremos una prueba zeta
si estamos trabajando con alguna
proporción pero cuando trabajamos con
medias usamos pruebas t y la razón del
porqué es que si trabajamos con un
estadístico z
al obtener este estadístico z lo que
hacemos es tomar la media muestral y
esta media restarle la media verdadera
que tenemos en la hipótesis nula así que
pondremos esta media con un subíndice
cero para diferenciarlas de la otra
después de tomar esta diferencia las
dividimos entre la desviación estándar
de la distribución muestral de la media
pero esta desviación estándar es algo
que desconocemos por esta razón usamos
un estadístico tema porque desconocemos
esta desviación estándar entonces
volvemos a tomar la diferencia entre la
media muestral y la media verdadera que
es la media que supusimos para nuestra
población y que viene de la hipótesis
nula y tratamos de estimar esto con la
desviación estándar de nuestra muestra
esto dividido entre la raíz cuadrada del
tamaño de la muestra
ahora si te sientes inspirado en este
momento pausa el vídeo e intenta
calcular este estadístico t bueno
incluso si no te sientes inspirado te
aliento a que lo intentes entonces esto
nos va a quedar la media que tenemos en
nuestra muestra la cual es 4 años menos
la media que tenemos en la población lo
cual estamos usando en esta hipótesis
nula es 5 años y esto dividido entre la
desviación estándar de la muestra que ya
sabemos que estos años que a su vez está
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de n
entre la raíz cuadrada de 25 y esto me
va a quedar bueno tengo 45 es menos 1 y
acá abajo me quedan 2 entre la raíz
cuadrada de 25 lo cual es 52 puntos y
esto es exactamente lo mismo que menos 1
que multiplican a 5 medios estamos
multiplicando por el recíproco o lo que
es lo mismo menos 5 medios
o menos 2.5 ahora lo que ramón tiene que
hacer es buscar este valor temp
en una tabla tema y si recordamos que la
distribución de un estadístico tema se
ve más o menos así entonces estamos
menos 2.5 por debajo de la media y por
lo tanto lo que necesita es calcular
esta área de aquí porque esta es la
probabilidad de estar así de lejos por
abajo de la media o incluso más abajo
esto nos dará el valor b y si ese valor
p es más pequeño que el nivel de
significancia es decir que un cierto
umbral que establezca ramón no lo acepta
el 25% o 1% entonces rechazaremos la
hipótesis nula y podremos sugerir su
sospecha que la media de los años de
experiencia de los profesores en su
escuela técnica es menor que 5 años
otra cosa que es importante tener en
mente es que nos dicen supongo que se
conocen todas las condiciones para la
inferencia es decir estamos suponiendo
que esta es una muestra aleatoria y que
cada una de las observaciones
individuales son verdaderamente
independientes o aproximadamente
independientes por lo tanto podemos
suponer o que ramón realizó estas
muestras con reemplazo o que la cantidad
de profesores que encuestó es menor que
el 10% y por último no olvides que
también tenemos la condición de
normalidad es decir que el observó que
la distribución muestral es
aproximadamente una distribución normal
todo esto ya lo hemos trabajado en
vídeos pasados así que esto es todo por
ahora nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo